Brian Johnson is a Silicon Valley
millionaire who made a lot of money in
e-commerce and related Industries but if
you've heard about this guy at all
you're most likely have heard of him
because of his bizarre increasingly
bizarre and desperate attempts to stop
himself from aging he's the guy who was
taking blood transfusions from his
teenage son on the theory that his son's
young blood will make him younger too or
something it's a scientific theory that
he developed after watching the series
Twilight uh presumably but fortunately
for his son he has recently abandoned
these vampiric efforts because it turns
out harvesting your child's life force
is impossible and the only thing it
accomplishes is making you look like a
freak so Johnson has since moved on to
other life extension techniques most of
which are sure to be just as pointless
if hopefully slightly less grotesk um
Johnson appeared on something called the
rich role podcast this week where he
offered his theories about life and
human immortality for two and a half
hours but one particular moment from
this conversation has gone viral we're
going to play that clip in a a minute
but before we do just to set the stage
here is a different 15-second snippet
right from the beginning of the video
that I think gives a very good window
into this guy and specifically into the
fact that he is basically full of crap
watch it's really simple I basically
don't trust anything in reality not
Authority not my mind not my perception
nothing I just trust data and numbers
and the only thing I believe in is I
don't want to
die now you notice right off the bat a
few things first of all the guy's 46
years old he's a multi-millionaire Tech
bro whose single-minded obsession is
avoiding death and aging and yet he
looks if anything older than he
is and and I know that criticism may
seem kind of Rich coming from me coming
from a guy who's 37 and looks like a 53y
old shop class teacher but the
difference is that I'm not trying to
look younger in fact I don't even
understand why looking younger is
considered automatically desirable
especially for men you know like why do
you care about as a as a man like why
what do you care about looking if you're
46 just look 46 why would you want to
look why at the age of 30 46 as a man
why would you want to look
25 even if that was possible but turns
out that it's not I mean looking younger
is a Fool's errand and if you try to
look younger you will inevitably just
end up looking like a guy who is trying
to look younger which is the worst thing
you can possibly look like now as for
the rest of what we saw and heard in
that clip it's the kind of empty-headed
nonsense that passes for profound these
days you know he says he doesn't trust
anything in reality doesn't even trust
his mind bro I don't even trust my mind
I don't trust anything trust nothing but
then he says that the only thing he does
trust is data and numbers well the
problem is that data and numbers Brian
exist in reality and the only way you
can access that information and
understand it and interpret it and
process it is with your mind so in order
to trust data and numbers you will need
to trust what exists in reality and your
mind so if you if you trust data and
numbers that means you also trust your
mind and your perception because the
only way that you can access the data
numbers is through your mind and your
perception which means that the
statement I don't trust anything in
reality I don't trust my mind I just
trust data and numbers is in every sense
meaningless it's a statement with no
content the only thing that has any
meaning is what he said at the very end
which is I just don't want to die now
that part I believe
and I and I understand it even I don't
want to die either in fact I am very
much opposed to
death I'm against it like I object to it
I don't want I don't want to do it I
don't want anyone I care about to do it
either but I will do it and so will
everyone I know and love and so will
Brian Johnson and all of his biohacking
efforts will be for not you know they
probably won't even extend his life by
any measurable degree at
all like he's not going to live forever
like he thinks he probably isn't even
going to live to 90
you know death is inevitable for
everyone and the thing that will
ultimately determine the time and manner
of your death will probably have a lot
more to do with your genetics than the
supplements you took if your house is
feeling a little bit chilly right now in
the thick of winter you may need to
consider window replacements I get it
for most homeowners window replacement
isn't something they've ever done before
and it may be a bit of a daunting task
luckily there's a company that will do
the work for you Renewal by Anderson is
your onstop shop for window design
manufacturer and installation Windows
play a crucial role in regulating indoor
temperatures if you notice a spike in
your heating or cooling bills it may be
due to inefficient windows don't put it
off any longer Renewal by Anderson
offers limited fully transferable and
best in the nation warranty coverage
right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free inhome consultation on
quality energy efficient Affordable
Windows or patio doors with special
financing options text Walsh to 200 300
for a free consultation to save $375 off
every window and $775 off every door
these savings won't last long so be sure
to check it out by texting Walsh to 200
300 that's Walsh to2 200 300 texting
privacy policy and terms of conditions
posted at text plan. us texting en rolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages message data rates may apply
reply stop to out go to
windowappointment now.com for full offer
details there's a reason why if you
listen to any interview with someone
who's like 105 or something that they
what do you notice about these these
people when you we've all heard the
interviews of someone's over the age of
100 like what's your secret you notice
something they never say anything about
the importance of vitamins or
supplements or intermittent fasting or
carbs or gluten or you know stealing
your son's blood or anything like that
never say any of that most of the time
they they they say that they smoked
cigarettes and drank whiskey every day
for 85 years which means that not only
did they outlive all of the health
health conscious people but they enjoyed
their lives a lot more in the process
which is the best of both worlds whereas
Brian Johnson has discovered the worst
of Both Worlds
he's living what seems to be a pretty
miserable life consumed by his fear of
of the inevitable and the chances are
he's just going to end up dead and
rotting in the ground before he hits 90
same as most of us so that brings us to
the clip that has gotten people's
attention but the the setup here was
necessary because we've established that
this guy is full of crap uh he's
consumed by Vanity and fear and he has
nothing that even resembles wisdom to
offer which makes sense of this part
listen we're right now in a moment at
the last moment
where like things kind of have been how
they have been but they're about to
change radically and in this new future
we can't predict what's going to happen
we no longer have the ability and so
we're living in a zeroth world and so
gen zero is a group of multiethnic
multinational people who rise up and
they say we are willing to courageously
step into the
future and we're willing to divorce or
open to divorce from ourselves all human
Norms all human Customs all human
thought and we're willing to say we're
wide
open about everything absolute Blank
Slate now the first thing to note here
is that there's nothing new about this
idea in many ways this is classic
Marxism you know many of the worst
tyrants in recent history sounded
exactly like this as many people have
already pointed out in response to this
clip Brian Johnson may as well be
quoting pot at this point and that's a
problem for his worldview um for a lot
of reasons one of them is that Johnson
wants to divorce himself from the past
and yet he doesn't know anything about
the past he wants to do something new
but he doesn't know what anyone was
doing before so there's no way to know
if the new thing is actually new which
in this case it isn't so he wants to
sound radically new and revolutionary
and instead he just ends up sounding
like a communist from 60 years ago but
for a moment Let's ignore the fact that
this radically new idea is actually
incredibly stale and rehashed no matter
how derivative they might be uh that
doesn't change the fact that these ideas
are also terrible you know divorcing
yourself from Human Norms from
traditions and customs and severing
yourself from the past to the extent
that such a thing is even possible is a
recipe for crushing misery Despair and
Decay as we're discovering right now in
fact Johnson Johnson's vision is one of
of of of a race of people who are
totally atomized and isolated existing
in a historical void with no connection
to their own past and a sort of cosmic
soundproof sanitized Booth where the
voices of their ancestors and the
traditions of the past cannot be heard
there's just nothing appealing or
desirable about such a world you know
that that is a world governed by
ignorance utterly devoid of wisdom no
sense of itself or its own place or its
purpose so just think about what it
would be like to apply this logic in any
specific circumstance in life so imagine
if you got into a car and then tried to
forget everything you knew about cars
everything you've ever been taught about
how to drive them how to operate them
what they are everything you've been
told about the rules of the road you
know because all that came from the past
all that came from older people and so
throw all that out on top of that throw
it any any navigation device made by
people in the past throw all of that out
clean slate right we're starting from
the
beginning well what happened happens
then if you could succeed in creating
this blank slate in your mind somehow
you'll just end up sitting in the
driveway staring blankly ahead or else
you'll pull out and you know uh drive
directly into a ditch at best you'll
drive around in circles and end up back
where you started that's because Blank
Slate you know the blank slate approach
leads to dysfunction and disaster in any
specific circumstance in life which
means that it'll lead to far greater
dysfunction and far more more disaster
when applied to life
itself now this is no surprise pure
unadulterated vanity never leads
anywhere good and that's what drives
this Blank Slate approach it's the
narcissism to assume that the past has
nothing to offer you at all that all the
traditions and beliefs and ideas of your
ancestors are not even worth considering
that all that came before you can be
discarded and forgotten and that you
yourself for some unknown and
unexplainable reason have it all figured
out it's like walking into somebody
else's house and they try to tell you
where the bathroom is because they've
been living here and they know and you
say NOP don't say anything I just got
here I know my way around I'll decide
where the bathroom is and then you go
and piss in the closet or something this
is how Brian Johnson thinks we should
approach
life and because he has no original
ideas what he doesn't realize is that
this is how our culture already
approaches life we've basically done the
thing that he's saying we should do look
around where is the Utopia That was
supposed to come with it nowhere to be
found just like Johnson supposedly
youthful looks it's a mirage and that is
why Brian Johnson is today canceled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts